when people meet me for the first time
on my job they often feel inspired to
share a revelation they've had about me
and it kind of goes something like this
hey I know why police chiefs like to
share their deep dark secrets with you
fill with your PhD in psychology and
your shiny bald head you're basically
the black dr. Phil right and for each
and every person who's ever said that to
me I do want to say thank you because
that was the first time I ever heard
that joke but for everybody else I
really hope you'll believe me when I
tell you know police chief likes talking
to me because they think I'm a clinical
psychologist and and also I'm not I have
no idea what your mother did to you and
I can't help no police chief's liked
talking to me because I'm an expert on a
problem that feels impossible for them
to solve racism in their profession now
my expertise comes from being a
scientist who studies how our minds
learn to associate blackness and crime
and misperceive black children is older
than they actually are and it also comes
from studying actual police behavior
which is how I know that every year
about one in five adults in the United
States has contact with law enforcement
out of those about a million are
targeted for police use of force and if
you're black you're two to four times
more likely to be targeted for that
force than if you're white but it also
comes from knowing what those statistics
feel like I've experienced the fear of
seeing an officer unclip their gun and
the panic of realizing that someone
might mistake my thirteen-year-old
godson as old enough to be a threat so
when a police chief or a pastor or an
imam or a mother when they call me after
an officer shoots another unarmed black
child I understand a bit of the pain in
their voice it's the pain of a heart
breaking when it fails to solve a deadly
problem breaking from trying to do
something that feels simultaneously
necessary
and impossible the way trying to fix
racism usually feels necessary and
impossible so police chiefs like talking
to me because I'm an expert but I doubt
they'd be lining up to lie down on dr.
Phil's couch if I told them all their
problems were hopeless all of my
research and the decade of work I've
done with my Center the Center for
policing equity actually leads me to a
hopeful conclusion amidst all the
heartbreak of race in America which is
this trying to solve racism feels
impossible because our definition of
racism makes it impossible but it
doesn't have to be that way so here's
what I mean the most common definition
of racism is that racist behaviors are
the product of contaminated hearts and
minds and we listen to the way we talk
about trying to cure racism you'll hear
it
we need to stamp out hatred we need to
combat ignorant right it's hearts and
minds now the only problem with that
definition is that it's completely wrong
both scientifically and otherwise one of
the foundational insights of social
psychology is that attitudes are very
weak predictors of behaviors but more
importantly than that no black community
has ever taken to the streets to demand
that white people would love us more
communities March to stop the killing
because racism is about behaviors not
feelings and even when civil rights
leaders like King and Fannie Lou Hamer
used the language of love the racism
they fought that was segregation and
brutality its actions over feelings and
every one of those leaders would agree
if a definition of racism makes it
harder to see the injury's racism causes
that's not just wrong a definition that
cares about the intentions of abusers
more than the harms to the abused that
definition of racism is racist but when
we change the definition of racism from
attitudes to behaviors we transform that
problem from impossible to solve all
because you can measure behaviors and
when you can measure a problem you can
tap into one of the only universal rules
of organizational success you got a
problem or a goal
you measure it you hold yourself
accountable to that metric so if every
other organization measures success this
way why can't we do that in policing it
turns out we actually already do police
departments already practice data-driven
accountability is just for crime at the
vast majority of police departments
across the United States use a system
called ComStat it's a process that when
you use it right right it identifies try
to crime data it tracks it and
identifies patterns and then it allows
departments to hold themselves
accountable to public safety goals right
it usually works either by directing
police attentions right and police
resources or changing police behavior
once they show up so if I see a string
of muggings in that neighborhood I'm
gonna want to increase patrols in that
neighborhood if I see a spike in
homicides I'm gonna want to talk to the
community to find out why and
collaborate on changes on police
behavior to tamp down the violence
now when you define racism in terms of
measurable behaviors you can do the same
thing you can create a ComStat for
justice and that's exactly what the
Center for policing equity has been
doing so let me tell you how that works
after a police department invites us in
we handle the legal stuff we engage with
the community our next step is to
analyze their data the goal of these
analyses is to determine how much doom
crime poverty neighborhood demographics
predict what's saying police use of
force okay so let's say that those
factors predict police will use force on
this many black people there so our next
question is how many black people
actually are targeted for police use of
force let's say it's this man so what's
up with the gap well a big portion of
the gap is the difference between what's
predicted by things police can't control
and what's predicted by things police
can control their policies and their
behaviors and what we're looking for are
the types of contact or the areas in the
city where that gap is biggest because
then we can tell our partners look here
solve this problem first it's actually
the kind of therapy police chiefs can
get behind because there is nothing so
inspiring in the face of our history of
racism
as a solvable problem because look if
the community in Minneapolis asked their
police department to remedy the moral
failings of race and policing I'm not
sure they know how to do that but if
instead the community says hey your data
say you're beating up a lot of homeless
folks you want to knock that off
that's something police can learn how to
do and they did so in 2015 the
Minneapolis PD let us know their
community was concerned they were using
force too often so we show them how to
leverage their own data to identify
situations where force could be avoided
and when you look at those data you'll
see that a disproportionate number of
their use of force incidents they
involve somebody who's homeless and
mental distress has a substance abuse
issue or some combination of all three
more than you expect
based on those factors I was just
telling you about so right there's the
gap next question is why well it turns
out homeless folks often need services
and when those services are unavailable
when they can't get their meds they lose
their spot in the shelter they're more
likely to engage in behaviors that end
up with folks calling the cops I'm gonna
cops show up they're more likely to
resist intervention oftentimes because
they haven't actually done anything
illegal they're literally just living
outside see that the problem wasn't a
need to train officers differently in
Minneapolis the problem was the fact
that folks were using the cops to treat
substance abuse and homelessness in the
first place so the city of Minneapolis
found a way to deliver social services
and city resources to the homeless
community before anybody ever called the
cops
now the problem isn't always
homelessness right sometimes the problem
is fear of immigration enforcement like
it was in Salt Lake City or it is in
Houston where the Chiefs had to come
forward and say we're not gonna deport
you just for calling 9-1-1 well the
problem is foot pursuits like it wasn't
Las Vegas where they had to train their
officers to slow down and take a breath
instead of allowing the adrenaline in
that situation to escalate it and it
searches in Oakland it's pulling folks
out of cars in San Jose it's the way
that they patrol the neighborhoods that
make up zone 3 in Pittsburgh and the
black neighborhoods closest to the
waterfront in Baltimore but in each city
if we can give them a solvable problem
they get busy solving it and together
our partners have seen an average of 25%
fewer arrests fewer use of force
incidents and 13% fewer officer related
injuries see essentially by identifying
the biggest gaps and directing police
attentions to solving it we can deliver
a data-driven vaccine against racial
disparities in policing now right now we
have the capacity to partner with about
40 cities at a time well that means if
we want the United States to stop
feeling exhausted from trying to solve
an impossible problem we're gonna need a
lot more infrastructure because our goal
is to have our tools be able to scale
the brilliance of dedicated organizers
and reform-minded Chiefs so to get there
we're gonna need the kind of collective
will that desegregated schools and one
the franchise for the sons and daughters
of former slaves so that we can build a
kind of healthcare system capable of
delivering our vaccine across the
country because our audacious idea is to
deliver a ComStat for justice to
departments serving 100 million people
across the United States in the next
five years
doing that would mean arming about a
third of the United States with tools to
reduce racial disparities in police
stops arrests and use of force but also
tools to reduce predatory cash bail and
mass incarceration family instability
and chronic mental health and substance
abuse issues and every other ill that
are broken criminal legal systems
aggravate because every unnecessary
arrest we can prevent saves the family
from the terrifying journey through each
one of those systems just like every gun
we can leave holstered saves an entire
community from a lifetime of grief look
each and every one of us we measure the
things that matter to us right
businesses measure profit good students
keep track of their grades families
chart the growth of their children with
pencil markings and door frames we all
measure the things that matter most to
us which is why we feel the neglect when
nobody's bothered to measure anything at
all for the past quarter millennium
we've defined the problems of race and
policing in a way that's functionally
impossible to measure but now the
science says we can just change that
definition and the folks at the Center
for policing equity I actually think we
may have measured more police behavior
than anyone in human history and that
means that once we have the will and the
resources to do it this could be the
generation that stops feeling like
racism is an unsolvable problem and
instead sees that what's been necessary
for far too long is possible thank you
[Applause]